-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How is Karen in Michigan doing
tonight?
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
President Biden yesterday ended
infrastructure negotiations
with Republican Senator Shelley
Moore Capito
and opened talks with
another group of GOP lawmakers,
led by Senator Bill Cassidy.
Dude, you can keep searching,
but you're not going to find
a reasonable group
of GOP senators.
You're like a woman who says,
"Maybe if I go
to a different
Buffalo Wild Wings,
I'll find a husband."
[ Light laughter ]
During an interview this week
with NBC news anchor
Lester Holt,
Vice President Kamala Harris
defended
the migrant situation
at the southern "bordah" --
border -- excuse me --
and said,
"There's not going to be
a quick fix."
I don't know, it seemed like
you had one the other day.
-Do not come. Do not come.
-According to a recent poll,
Brooklyn Borough President
Eric Adams leads the field
in the New York
mayoral Democratic primary,
ahead of former presidential
hopeful Andrew Yang.
Said Yang, "What the hell
is Brooklyn?"
[ Light laughter ]
Right-wing cable channel Newsmax
reportedly turned down
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz
earlier this year,
after he approached them
about a job.
But if you knew what kind of job
he was asking for,
you'd turn him down, too.
Federal Prosecutors recently
arrested a Pennsylvania man
who allegedly posed
as former President Trump
to collect funds for a fake
re-election organization
but instead used the money
for personal expenses.
What did they charge him with?
Plagiarism?
Starbucks announced yesterday
it's reintroducing
its 10-cent discount
for customers who bring
personal reusable cups.
Meanwhile, Dunkin' customers
can save a buck
if they just
hold out their hands.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
That's our Dunkin' customer?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] Feel -- Feel
like that fights the joke.
[ Laughter ]
"Off to my business meeting!"
Ford yesterday unveiled
its new hybrid engine
compact pickup truck.
So if you love
driving a pickup,
but you care
about the environment,
I kind of just want
to learn more about you.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a travel agency
has announced plans
to offer a "Friends"-themed
cruise next year.
And nothing says
"I miss the '90s"
more than still using
a travel agent.
And that, everybody,
was a monologue.